a national idea that was built on the
shared pursuit of Excellence has since
perverted into this new national
identity that that's taken the form of
this victimhood grievance Olympics where
there is no gold medalist it is our
nation and our national identity that
loses in the end and that's the heart of
this whole new book you know that that's
why I wrote the book is someone who
needed to expose this in some ways as a
first generation American looking at
this not as somebody who inherited
America but whose parents came to this
country voluntarily with their two feet
to to be part of that national identity
and yet now 40 years later found a new
national identity centered on on this
black hole of victimhood instead
foreign
responsibility that these boards have to
their shareholders are you surprised or
was there an example of a company where
the shareholders were able to fight this
effectively I mean I remember literally
on my show five or six years ago when
Google AdSense was clamping down on
everybody I had a couple guests in a row
and I was calling for it too it's like
where are the shareholders who are going
well wait a minute put censorship aside
for a second if they are not putting ads
on certain things am I being hurt as a
shareholder like like was are there any
examples where the shareholders actually
accomplish anything or lawsuits or
anything not a ton yet that's what I'm
working on man all right all right I
started the strive subscribe as a new
form competing with BlackRock we we just
sent a public letter to Chevron calling
out a lot of these you know a lot of
these behaviors that crucially though
were forced on them by BlackRock State
Street and Vanguard in many cases
Chevron
actually said initially that they
opposed these proposals but then the
large shareholders vote for them anyway
and this is the problem Drew is that a
lot of a lot of the movement you know
that that you know you know you would
you would advocate for
shareholder-centric power what they miss
is that the 21st century version of this
problem is different and they've thrown
a thrown a tripwire that a lot of us
fell for which was that they said okay
Milton Friedman you said that
shareholders rule right and Company
management teams report to shareholders
well guess what
we are the shareholder
we are demanding that you the company
management adopt these social agendas
you're not betraying your fiduciary duty
to us you're actually working for us
because we the shareholder Milton
Friedman all along said it Rule and you
owe the duty to us and we the
shareholders are demanding it so here's
the fallacy in that argument but but
that's that's effectively what allowed
this this problem to spread like
wildfire is the parlance of fiduciary
duty to shareholder misses the fact that
the shareholder IU shareholder air
quotes is actually the one pushing the
agenda so to do this we have to get a
little academic for a second dude yeah I
got a bright audience
but okay so so the whole shareholder
Primacy Doctrine came from it was a
Vestige of 20th century corporate law
and and even Friedman I thinking in the
late 20th century that solved a problem
called the separation of ownership and
control okay so the CEO has control of
the firm but the shareholder owns The
Firm they're not the same person that
gives rise to what's called a principal
agent conflict the shareholders the
principal the CEO is the agent leads to
the private jet problem of you know CEOs
that are flying on private jets flying
using the shareholder Capital to do it
you know that RJR Nabisco problem
overspending well how do you close that
Gap it's by imposing a fiduciary duty on
the CEO to the shareholder so Milton
Friedman said the CEO can't pursue these
social agendas without serving interest
of the shareholder that's where the
fiduciary duty came from that's a 20th
century stuff it's called the separation
of ownership and control
the 21st century version of this problem
is different
it is not the separation of ownership
and control
it is the separation of ownership and
ownership
and what I mean by that is the parties
who now then claim to be the owners the
shareholders of these companies like
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
they are not the actual owners of those
companies because they launched these
so-called passive index funds that
aggregated trillions of dollars in the
last 15 years
that or the money of everyday citizens
who are the actual owners of the company
but invest vehicles
that were managed by a managerial Clinic
that then showed up in the boardrooms of
those companies and said you know what I
am the shareholder I'm demanding you
behave this way but so basically in
essence so the average shareholder
probably didn't even know what was going
on
the everyday citizen whose money is
being invested
through a Plinko chips mediated
Financial system that then goes into a
pension fund that then asks an
investment consultant where to invest
that then invests in the fund manager by
BlackRock that then invests in a company
it's such an intermediated system but
the actual owner of capital has no idea
that that state pension fund and its
board member and its investment staff
and BlackRock were betraying their
interests by representing viewpoints in
corporate America's boardrooms in the
boardrooms of companies like Chevron the
one I wrote to earlier this week
in ways that the owner of capital had no
idea was actually happening so that's
really how this plays out in reality
where the parties who claim to be the
shareholders are not the actual
shareholders and that's the big problem
okay so with that in mind let's shift a
little bit to the sort of spiritual part
of this or the the generational the
cultural part that you're talking about
uh you mentioned before from uh Indian
background you grew up in the midwest I
mean I suspect that whether it was your
parents or great grandparents or
whatever it might be that came from
India I'm guessing they didn't come with
a lot and they probably had to work hard
and I'm guessing that they don't feel
very guilty about your success no they
don't and that's the thing whether
they're Republican Democrat the thing
you'll find about immigrants who come to
this country through the front door and
I distinguished that you know for coming
to the back of it legal immigrants to
the front or by and large come to this
country to pursue Excellence to pursue
their dreams to pursue Excellence
without having to apologize for it
leaving places that were
anti-meritocratic to come to a
meritocratic nation where are regardless
of your Creed or skin color you can
achieve anything you want with your own
hard work and commitment and dedication
that used to be our national identity
we now have a new national identity
built on victimhood instead and one
thing you know my parents taught me from
a young age
is that hardship is not the same thing
as you're going to encounter hardship in
your life it's part of what teaches you
who you are
but we live now in a moment where where
kids are taught the Next Generation by
the way I know I was first generation my
parents were the immigrants I was born
in America the second and third
generation even in the Asian American
communities are being taught this new
narrative to say that you know what the
more you think of yourself as a victim
as a person of color or whatever your
victim of narrative is that's how you
get ahead in life not by actually
unapologetically embracing the pursuit
of excellence and and that's become our
new national identity a national idea
that was built on the shared pursuit of
Excellence has since perverted into this
new national identity that that's taken
the form of this victimhood grievance
Olympics where there is no gold medalist
it is our nation and our national
identity that loses in the end and
that's the heart of this whole new book
you know that that's why I wrote the
book is someone who needed to expose
this in some ways as a first generation
American looking at this not as somebody
who inherited America but whose parents
came to this country voluntarily with
their two feet to to be part of that
national identity and yet now 40 years
later found a new national identity
centered on on this black hole of
victimhood instead
did did the neolibs or the libs or the
Neo progressives or whatever version
whatever language you want to use around
that is there some reason that they
inherently failed with this you know
that that they didn't defend the ideas
that their ancestors came here for well
enough
yes I think some of it was this
generational insecurity uh I think it's
this idea that when you haven't
encountered hardship actually you begin
to hunger for it
you know there's something about the
human psyche that's a funny thing we
require
hardship and the experience of
overcoming it to remind ourselves The
Contours of our soul of who we are I
gave the the high school commencement
address
to my own high school where I graduated
I gave convention when I graduated what
in 2003 they invited me back to give an
updated address last year at last year's
commencement and and it struck me that
was the first graduating class that had
an in-person graduation we're not a
single member of that class was even
born on the day that those twin those
Twin Towers were hit by those two planes
and that defined part of my high school
experience when I was in high school I
was AP History Class or U.S history
class at that particular time it was
you know it was it was a defining moment
this is you're looking at a generation
where not a single person had been
through that experience and I'm not
saying that it had to be 911 but you
know I think a generation that actually
has is on the receiving end of that
intergenerational wealth transfer that
hasn't had to necessarily as a either as
a citizen or as an individual fight for
the kind of right to be able to be proud
needs to then see themselves as the
victim of some other hardship instead
and so you could argue maybe it's not
even their fault this is just what the
Arc of History has dealt Our Generation
Millennials gen Z and younger to have to
think of themselves as encountering
hardships that don't even actually exist
and then reinvent that victimhood
narrative until a new one is dealt in
its place instead but the problem is if
you live in that victimhood narrative
for long enough you're not even going to
have the fortitude to fight that
hardship when it actually comes maybe
that's China maybe it's something else
whatever it is if we don't turn this
culture around I think we will have
actually lost the very fortitude that we
might have gotten from actually
encountering more part of the diagnosis
for me if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics and instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell